avant toute chose je voudrais prendre un
petit moment pour à consacrer toutes les
personnes
concernées par les troubles psychiques
et leurs proches qui nous ont quittés
malheureusement trop tôt autour de moi
j'ai même plus assez de doigts sur la
main pour les compter donc je vais que
tous ensemble en fait on se lève pour
applaudir pour prendre un temps pour eux
si vous voulez
c'est très important pour moi
merci merci beaucoup
[Musique]
c'est applaudissements sont pas
seulement pour
ces personnes je vais vous raconter
l'histoire d'une jeune femme que j'ai
rencontrée ce dimanche dernier donc
elle avait 24 ans elle était mère d'une
jeune petite fille de 7 mois j'avais
voulu en fait partir
ce dimanche voir ma petite sœur qui a 10
ans de moins faire un tournoi de cheval
ma petite sœur est passée 4e et cette
jeune femme est passée 5e et au dernier
saut d'obstacle en fait elle a de retiré
les rênes elle a fait une bascule avant
et le cheval lui retombé dessus et elle
est morte sur le coup devant nous tous
pourquoi je parle de ça aujourd'hui
c'est parce que du coup je pensais
depuis dimanche constamment et parce que
aussi pour moi c'est important en fait
ça fait relativité sur beaucoup de
choses en fait sur à la fois le vivant
l'amour le présent le vivant ensemble
c'est pourquoi on fait les choses
comment on les fait et
surtout cette notion du temps aussi de
prendre le temps en fait parce que moi
le premier donc je vais vous raconter
mon histoire mais j'ai tendance à
toujours penser au coup d'après dans le
futur parce que voilà je suis
entrepreneur je dois faire des choses et
en fait ça m'a vraiment fait penser et
relativiser sur imagine Maxime c'était
ta petite sœur qui était tombée dimanche
imagine du coup voilà donc je voulais
juste avoir une pensée pour cette jeune
femme sa famille et ses proches voilà
donc c'est une chose qui arrive une fois
tous les 100 ans apparemment c'est un
petit peu de Rome il trouve que j'étais
là ce jour là avec tous les enfants
autour qui ont tout vu et voilà c'était
important pour moi de d'en parler
aujourd'hui
je m'appelle Maxime Perez j'ai 29 ans
j'ai eu la chance d'avoir une enfance
plutôt
tranquille donc j'ai eu la chance d'être
de grandir en banlieue parisienne jamais
manqué de rien j'ai toujours eu des
facilités à l'école
j'ai été piqué par
chinois donc pas le covid mais juste que
le virus chinois à l'âge de 15 ans parce
que ma mère travaillait en Asie suite à
cela en fait j'ai enchaîné des stages
dès mes 15 ans en Asie pour apprendre le
chinois donc parce que j'avais vraiment
comme optique de partir vivre en Chine
chose que j'ai fait à partir de mes j'ai
fait une école de commerce
en langue étrangère appliquée au
business en Asie me voilà en Asie
et en fait après deux ans et demi sur
place en fait je me rendais compte que
en fait j'avais pas ma place en école de
commerce dans le sens où je trouvais que
je payais beaucoup trop cher mon diplôme
parce que j'apprenais sur place
désolé et en fait ce qui est très je les
remercie beaucoup mes parents c'est que
en fait j'ai fait un dîner avec mes
parents c'était de pas payer ma dernière
année en fait me servir de cet argent
pour parcourir la Chine tout seul pour
essayer de créer des enfin j'avais des
idées de business déjà je travaillais
déjà pour une marque de vêtements moi il
s'appelle le slip français pour le
développer alors que j'étais encore
étudiant et de là m'est venu l'idée donc
de profiter du temps que j'avais à ce
moment là et de l'énergie surtout et du
visa que va être obtenu mon école de
commerce même si j'ai pas payé l'école
et de suite à cela donc je suis parti
pendant un an donc j'ai parcouru toute
la Chine tout seul
[Musique]
vive idée de en fait d'appeler ma mère
au secours en lui disant voilà maxime
est en train de partir en connaît plus
maximum en fait tout simplement il faut
faire quelque chose donc ma mère en fait
ce qui s'est passé c'est qu'elle a pris
le premier avion tu as une superwoman
elle a réussi à négocier avec il se
trouve que mon oncle et maintenant ce
sont des grands médecins et eux n'ont
pas voulu filer ce médicament à la mer
parce que c'est interdit par la loi et
si on se fait attraper par le
enfin la donne on peut aller en prison
mais ma mère c'est démener à trouver un
médecin qui a accepté de lui donner ma
mère arrive en Chine elle a réussi à me
retrouver et en fait étape par étape en
fait elle m'a drogué à mon insu dans mon
verre pour en fait me calmer en fait me
faire comprendre que je pouvais rentrer
même si en fait parce que moi dans cette
dans cet état là je vais en rendais
compte de rien et en fait j'étais
persuadé qu'en fait super j'allais
rentrer auprès de la princesse et que
j'allais revenir après mais en fait
c'est pas du tout donc ça c'est vraiment
le début du croisement le chemin de mon
histoire
c'est quoi voilà me voilà arrivé à Paris
je pense que tout va bien que je vais
juste avoir une petite inspection
auprès du médecin donc maintenant tu es
là en fait on propose de prendre un
médicament donc de base moi j'étais anti
médicament et donc je refuse à ce
moment-là en fait il y a deux infirmiers
assez costaud qui arrivent qui me
déshabille et qui me font une piqûre sur
les fesses
et de là en fait je me réveille
apparemment cinq jours après attaché en
contention dans une salle blanche s'en
est suivi en fait je savais pas du tout
ce qui s'est passé en fait à ce moment
là on se réveille
évidemment je me suis ça je souhaite
passer à mon pire ennemi souvent ce que
je dis de se retrouver à attacher en
contention dans une salle sans savoir si
je suis en France en Chine c'est
franchement hyper compliqué à vivre de
là en fait on m'explique que je suis là
dans le cas des 12 jours donc qui sait
ce que c'est les deux jours je pense pas
que vous le sachiez mais en fait c'est
un protocole qui existe depuis 2013
quand on est placé sous contrainte en
fait on est placé à l'isolement et au
bout de 12 jours on doit pas prendre un
avocat et passer dans le juge des
libertés pour vérifier bien fonder de
son placement en contention donc autant
vous dire que moi j'étais complètement
perché à ce moment là on m'explique que
je dois prendre un avocat que je vais te
passer devant le juge des libertés mais
c'est il y a rien de plus violent en
fait
donc je vis ça
[Musique]
en fait si j'en ai beaucoup voulu à mes
parents que j'en avais eu dans la
famille mais comme j'avais jamais dit
donc ça c'est un truc très français en
fait c'est le tabou familial je vous
invite tout ça vraiment en parler en
famille parce que franchement c'est
je trouve ça insensé de pas en parler en
famille pour justement éviter ce genre
de catastrophe
suite à cela ce qui s'est passé c'est
que
de savoir c'est qu'il y a deux à 3% de
bipolaire en France et qui a 20% de
suicide donc faites le calcul parmi vos
contacts Instagram LinkedIn Facebook ce
que vous voulez faites 2 à 3 % et faites
un cinquième de ça c'est le nombre de
personnes qui vont en fait se suicider
et ça c'est parce qu'en fait elles sont
pas assez volées dans la société
française donc parenthèse fermée
donc on va prendre tout ça et là j'ai
une super psychiatre à ce moment-là qui
m'explique parce que moi j'étais encore
dans le petit de vouloir sortir le plus
vite possible de l'hôpital psychiatrique
pour retourner en Chine et là voilà
manque de bol je tombe sur une
psychiatre à ce moment-là qui m'explique
qu'en fait c'est fini quoi que je peux
oublier mes startups que je peux oublier
une vistaf que je peux oublier une vie
amoureuse normale que je publier les
sorties que je dois avoir une vie genre
complètement neutre et entre guillemets
plus rien faire de ma vie donc super dur
à encaisser
au final ma mère a réussi à négocier
pour que je sorte de l'hôpital
je retourne à la maison donc en vrai moi
j'ai eu beaucoup de chance dans la
malchance parce que j'avais la chance
d'avoir un toit d'avoir de quoi manger
tous les jours c'est pas le cas de tout
le monde en fait parce que quand on est
à l'hôpital très souvent en fait mon
père son emploi on perd son logement si
on n'est pas épaulé par sa famille mais
c'est pas par hasard en fait qu'il y a
30% des gens dans la rue en France qui
ont un trouble aussi c'est important de
le savoir
et
moi je suis resté au final 17 mois dans
ma chambre enfermée sans sortir de ma
chambre j'ai pas répondu à un seul appel
de mes potes même si je les remercie
tous les jours parce que notamment un
qui m'a appelé les Clément tous les
jours pendant 17 mois alors que j'ai
jamais répondu donc d'où l'importance
des potes dans ce moment-là
et mais bon c'est pas pour autant que
j'ai quand même pas fait j'ai fait une
tentative de suicide voilà après c'est
le dessin je suis toujours là donc
c'est voilà mais c'est pas facile de
passer par ce genre de thème comme vous
pouvez l'imaginer suite à cela je vais
un peu accélérer mais je pourrais parler
pendant des heures mais dans l'idée ce
qui s'est passé c'est que donc super dur
en fait j'étais dans le déni parce qu'en
fait j'avais aussi honte de tout ce que
j'avais pu faire dans ces phases dites
de Manille parce que voilà j'ai pas
dormi pendant plusieurs mois j'étais
dans l'excès j'étais
voilà tout un panel de choses que je
vous invite à découvrir sur la vularité
mais aussi des très bonnes choses et des
bons côtés notamment la créativité et
suite à cela en fait j'ai eu un vrai
premier déclic c'est ma petite sœur qui
est venue voir dans ma chambre à
l'époque et donc en 2010 donc c'est en
2015 le diagnostic en 2017 et qui m'a
juste dit mais Maxime en fait je te
reconnais plus tu es plus mon enfer tes
mous tu es chiant il est où on va enfin
et là je vous avoue que ça m'a mis une
grosse claque dans la gueule et c'est de
là en fait que j'ai décidé de me motiver
de là j'ai décidé d'aller de l'avant
j'ai commencé à marcher tout simplement
j'ai compté parce que je devais le faire
pour autre chose j'ai marché 15000 km en
5 ans parce que je marche 10 km par jour
pour trouver l'équilibre et pour aussi
atténuer les effets secondaires des
médicaments parce que forcément qui dit
bipolarité du traitement avec effets
secondaires donc notamment moi le mien
il attaque Merlin j'ai des tremblements
et suite à la contention et genre de
choses j'ai pas le problème quand je
suis enfermé enfin voilà forcément il y
a pas mal de choses à prendre en compte
on oublie aussi que en fait bipolaire
c'est pas juste lunatique
c'est quand même le handicap le plus
classé numéro 6 niveau mondial donc
c'est pas rien et
je me décide d'avancer d'accepter la
maladie je me fais ré hospitaliser mais
cette fois dans un centre expert où il y
avait que des bipolaires
là pour la première fois en fait je sens
j'accepte la maladie donc j'en parle
avec les autres patients la différence
de la première hospitalisation et c'est
là qu'en fait en parlant aux autres j'ai
une espèce de là c'est le vrai deuxième
déclic je pourrais citer au milieu du
chaos et de l'opportunité de sous mais
en fait peut-être que la solution c'est
peut-être en fait de
pour avancer pour moi c'était en fait de
servir pour guérir en fait de créer une
structure pour en fait aider les
personnes comme moi je me dis c'est pas
possible que je sois le seul et si en
plus moi j'ai eu la chance de faire une
grande école avoir une famille qui me
soutient j'imagine pas les autres et le
soutien qu'ils ont
donc de là j'ai l'idée de créer donc ma
première association qui s'appelait
bipolaire et fier et ensuite rebelote là
je suis reparti en marchant comme quand
j'étais en Chine et en fait j'ai fait
toute la France pour voir un peu tout ce
qui existait on peut au niveau de
l'Europe aussi et de là je me suis
inspiré c'est en fait c'est mon côté
entrepreneur qui est revenu sur le
dessus et aussi parce qu'en fait j'avais
des convictions et j'avais surtout envie
de me prouver à moi-même que ok je suis
bipolaire et c'est pas ça qui va
m'empêcher de faire quoi que ce soit
et dans l'idée
je vous invite vraiment à vous
renseigner donc sur l'association que
j'ai créé donc qui s'appelle la maison
perchée donc l'idée c'est que c'est la
première association qui vient en aide
qui est non médicalisée spécialisée pour
les jeunes de 18 à 40 ans qui vendent à
toute personne concernée et leurs
proches et aussi l'objectif c'est de
sensibiliser le grand public mais
au-delà de ça c'est vraiment une
aventure humaine et on prouve en fait
plus grande fierté là dedans c'est de me
prouver en fait que finalement j'étais
capable et ma psychiatre qui était là le
jour du déclic en 2017 on avait dit au
début
le Maxime en fait c'est de la folie on
n'a jamais vu un malade et d'autres
malades c'est pas possible en fait et là
il y a encore un mois elle m'a fait
visité parce qu'il se trouve que voilà
donc maintenant on est 70 associations
on a une plateforme en ligne qui
cartonne on arrive à toucher des gens
dans toute la France et même à
l'étranger on ouvre en premier local là
à Paris et comme quoi c'est possible en
fait et donc
la conclusion c'est vraiment de vous
renseigner de prendre le temps
parce que c'est important en fait et
parce que c'est peut-être que vous
n'êtes pas concerné aujourd'hui
et vous serez peut-être demain ou
après-demain peut-être que ça sera votre
cousin votre pote votre soeur et en fait
l'intérêt de mon associé c'est vraiment
d'éviter aux gens de perdre ces deux
années que j'ai perdu cette tentative du
Sud et en fait c'est vraiment la brique
manquante du parcours de soins et voilà
en tout cas il y a plein de moral à
cette histoire je pourrais parler encore
pendant des heures en vrai j'ai plein
d'histoires à raconter vous pouvez aller
voir sur le site on a fait plein de
choses magnifiques sur nous avec les
co-fondatrices mais c'est vraiment moi
c'est une phrase que j'aime beaucoup de
Jacques Brel qui dit
vous vous cassez la gueule vous cassez
la gueule on meurt pas de se casser la
gueule et moi je rajouterais mes pour y
arriver on peut arriver tout seul voilà
merci
[Applaudissements]